en 2010 les rushs installèrent montréal
se comptaient sur les doigts d'une seule
main
aujourd'hui il y en aurait autour de
milliers sur les toits des entreprises
des résidences ou des bâtiments publics
comme ici au palais des congrès la
question yat il maintenant trop
d'abeilles sur le territoire de la
métropole
l'entreprise avait hall gère plus de 350
ruches en milieu urbain une éducation
qui a eu trop de ruches aurait voulu
dire une perte de production donc moins
de kilos produisant de miel et on le
voit pas à tous les arts on a une
production est à peu près stable à
l'impasse en une année un peu difficile
ça arrive mais cette année on voit on
arrive dans des productions record
alvéoles concentre surtout ses activités
dans les quartiers centraux de la ville
l'espace dont dispose des abeilles de
nos ruches pour se nourrir est en
général pas mal plus limitée que les
ruches installées en campagne j'ai
trente ruches en fait il est trop limité
selon alain péris cas qui a des ruches
en estrie et à montréal ce que je
constate c'est qu'avec les mêmes
méthodes ont je récolte peut-être un
cinquième ou sixième du miel que je
récolte à la campagne avec les mêmes
rabais
l'un des problèmes que pose le manque d
espace dit il c'est qu'ils habitent trop
à l'étroit ont tendance à s aimer à
créer de nouvelles ruches et parfois à
devenait plus agressive
il ya une personne sur cinq mille qui
peut subir un choc anaphylactique à
cause d'une piqûre d'une abeille si à
trop de ruches les rejoint avoir
tendance à essaimer et d'une certaine
façon ça peut mettre à risque
même la vie de certaines personnes
alexandre mais clean pense au contraire
que la cohabitation est possible comme
le démontre l'expérience de plusieurs
grandes villes dont londres avec ses
4000 ruche où paris paris 1 700 ha ruche
pour une superficie qui est trois fois
plus petit que montréal alors si on a à
peu près 500 ruches à montréal on
président prendrait trois fois plus de
place
le font ça depuis dix ans avec succès ça
fonctionne bien on déballe production
donc non je pense aucun problème tant
que c'est bien géré tant qu'on est
d'abord les désaffections de celles
qu'on fait bien 7
ce qui est certain c'est que
l'engouement pour la production de miel
en ville n'a pas l'air d'une mode
passagère
aujourd'hui l'apiculture urbaine devrait
s'orienter vers des projets
communautaires éducatif et non plus vers
le désir d'une personne d'avoir une
ruche où plusieurs sur son toit ou sur
son balcon ici norma grandin radio
canada montréal